a string of talks
uh starting with simon do from
university of washington
he's going to talk to us about offline
uh and two player zero sum marco games
simon take it away i will thank you yeah
good job for a question all right
uh yeah thanks for the introduction um
hello everyone i'm very happy to be here
talking about our uh recent work on the
offline multi-agent reinforced learning
um
this is a joint work with my student
stephen trey from
uw
uh so today we're going to talk about
two players through some markov games so
uh because this is a multi-agent
reinforcement workshop so i don't think
i need to
motivate this problem so you know
basically this problem talk about um
two players compete against each other
and uh each has a strategy
and our goal is to find the national
equilibrium
which is a pair of
strategies that no player can do better
by unilaterally changing the policy
and for this problem there are many
applications like poker go chess games
also some in investment as well
so this is the standard uh two players
or some markov games so today um i'm
going to talk about
the offline setting of this two-player
some game
um so
in online setting usually we can control
an agent
which is interacting with the
environment and based on the collected
data this agent can update his policy
nowadays often represented by some
neural networks so this is an online
setting
for the offline reinforcement learning
setting
we are given a big data set which are
collected from the past interactions
using some policies or sometimes even a
set of policies
um
and then we just use this big data set
to train the policy and we hope that
this learn policy give good performance
when we deploy it
okay
so the motivation for offline reinforced
learning is that in many settings uh
real-world applications uh you know
online interaction with environment can
be very costly
so we really want to use existing data
to learn good policy
um so this talk will be focusing on uh
learning and nash equilibrium in this
offline um to publish some markov games
and we will focus on what are the
conditions we need to have in order to
learn the national difference
so before getting into two players or
some setting uh let me first review a
little bit on
what we know about offline single agent
reinforcement learning
so uh so here's a quick review of what
is single in reinforcement here we are
controlling an agent uh which is
interacting with the environment at each
time step uh the agent is at some state
let's call it st
and uh the agent takes some actions a t
uh the agent receives some reward based
on some reward function that depends on
state and action
and the state or the environment
transits the agent to the next state
according to some transition probability
uh which may depend on the time step uh
which is actually known as pt here
and move to the next state as t plus one
okay and here let's say we consider the
episode exciting so for each episode you
have
a planning horizon or the absolute
length h so basically this kind of
interaction repeat for h times so this
is a single agent reinforcement
and the goal of single agent learning is
to learn good policy
or you can view policy as a mapping from
state to action basically tells you
which action to choose based on the
current state you're at
and the goal is to maximize the total
expected total reward or the value
function
um which is defined this way this
expectation over the policy and the
transition
uh say starting from a fixed state let's
say s1
and in terms of a learning problem i
want to learn a policy that is close to
the optimal uh policy
which is measured by the difference of
the value in terms of the this policy
and the open policy
okay because this is a standard single
enforced learning um and here let's say
we consider this most basic setting the
tabular setting where we have finite
state
uh finite actions
and there's a reward scanning is from
zero to one in this case the sample
complexity
will depend uh polynomially on these
factors sah and the one epsilon
okay so this is a single agent
reinforced learning and for the offline
setting um
this is the offline single-enforcement
basically we have let's say n
um trajectories each directory have in
total h
steps for each step we have a data set
of
of this form say we have current states
action reward next state
and um
the key notion in this
uh single agent reinforcement or offline
reinforcement is that
we
say that this data set is collided from
a distribution
which we denote as zero where rho
is
uh the data collection or the behavioral
policy so we use this policy
to collect data okay and you can think
of this policy as a even as a mixed
policy with different uh
you know fixed policies and this is like
a mixture of policies as well so
basically what we care about is this
distribution zero that generates um this
data set
okay so this theorem is a state action
distribution that depends on uh the uh
policy row and uh
this uh mdp
transition matrix p
okay
and again go with the same we want to
learn a policy from this data set uh
without any action based environment
such that the policy is near optimal say
raising up some
arrow
to the output policy
okay
so uh different from the online setting
the natural question for the offline
setting is that what kind of assumption
we need to make on this distribution
that generates data
under which we can learn your policy so
a simple self experience is that you can
think of if the open policy can
basically some state
and actions but our data collection
policies
does not uh visit those state action for
that case you cannot hope to you know
learn a good policy or learn your policy
because you don't have the coverage over
uh some state actions that are visited
by the open policy but here they say you
don't have any information about those
uh stated actions
okay
so there's a long line of work on single
agent
offline reinforced learning and
researchers have identified this
assumption it's called single policy
coverage assumption
uh which is shown to have a be both
necessary and sufficient so
first of all it cannot be weakened
because if you do have some uh
actions that is
um so here by definition uh the
definition of single assumption is that
the behavior policy only covers a single
open policy
so this is necessary because
uh if you have some state action that is
not visited or not uh collected by your
behavior or data collection policy then
you cannot hope for to learn on your own
policy on the other hand this is also
sufficient because we do have some
algorithm based on pessimism
uh to learn with a polynomial number of
samples so formally this assumption
states that there exists
some constant let's call it a c single
such that's the
kind of expensive ratio and this
importance rate
uh between the distribution induced by
open policies let's say pi star
and this distribution induced by your
behavior policy this importance weight
is upper bounded by
um
this constant cc single okay
there's some stronger assumption uh
people have made in previous work
showing like you cover all state actions
but this is much uh weaker because you
only need to cover the state actions
visited by the output policy okay and in
terms of the scaling uh this single can
be uh in the best case it can be one uh
when say row equals to pi star then um
say single becomes one but you know it
can also be infinity uh if you do not
have some uh you have some state action
that you do not cover by this behavioral
policy
okay so simple convexity will eventually
depend on this uh concept okay so in
terms of algorithm uh there's a
automatic
pessimism which basically penalizes
uncertain uh policies so we'll be more
conservative when choosing the
output policy
and for this setting there are also
optimal bonds and
where scaling is s
h cubed c single divided by epsilon
squared
okay so this is what we know about uh
single agent offline reinforcement so
this work we study the two players there
are some markov games um
so the sighting is similar um
so here we are controlling there are two
agents um at each time step they are all
at both sides some state ft and they
choose a pair of actions a t and bt so a
is action for we call max player b is
action for the mean player
and then
they receive some reward based on the
state and this action pair
and the
environment will transit these two
players to the next state according to
the transition function and again this
repeat for h times h is the plan horizon
so this is a zero sum game so um the max
player
uh with a sequence of actions a1 to h
they try uh this
this player tries to maximize expected
total reward
and we also have a meme player
mission action sequence b1 to bh
who tries to minimize the uh
expected total reward
so
our key insight actually is just by
starting a much simpler version of the
two players or some games uh michael
games we call it zero sum bandit
uh basically it's a special case of zero
sum markov games uh in the case that uh
h
equals one so basically you don't need
to do any planning
there's no transition at all and you
have a fixed state so s equals one okay
so in this case only the reward function
matters basically the max player wants
to try
tries to find a you know action uh such
that can meet maximizes reward and uh i
mean
player tries to find minimum reward
okay so this is uh the setting um so
again we'll study the most basic tabular
setting we have finites number of states
finite number of actions for both
players two words bounded by
one and
some complex will scale with these
factors
okay um
so in terms of the uh uh we also need to
introduce some notions in this setting
because it's uh
some game um so we have a policy pair
let's call it mu and new
so the max player
is playing this policy mu and mean
player plays is pausing new so generally
these policies are sarcastic policies
because this is a two-player game
so the policy is mapping from the state
to a
distribution over the actions
so similar to single agent setting we
can define the queue function the value
function rescue function given a set of
apparel policies new and new is defined
as the
starting from state and a pair of
actions the
expected reward
from this time step
h
and then following the policy pair
mu and
and for the volume function it is the um
expected reward from this
state s following this policy pair mu
and nu
um
so here we also need to define the best
response and uh for for both max and
mean players so given a policy for the
bank's player the best response
for this policy it's a policy for the
mean player uh satellite can minimize uh
this volume function
um okay so that's why it's called best
response and notation we denoted as
v
mu star
which is the value of the best response
for given policy of the max player
and also we can define the best response
for the mean players
by symmetry
so for a
min player policy nu the max
best response volume
is v star nu
which is a value achieved by
maximizing or the all policy of the max
player for this given mean place policy
nuke
okay so a nash equilibrium uh say mu
star nustar satisfied that
the new star is basically the best
response for mu star and mu star is the
best response for new star it's a
standard result in game theory
and
so we eventually want to output a pair
of policies say mu and nu so want to
measure how good it is
the measure we use is called duality gap
which is the
difference between the uh best response
values
of the minion player and the max player
okay so this is the theology gap and our
goal is to find
a pair of policies such that this gap is
more than epsilon
okay so okay now let's study what is the
offline setting so similar to single
agent setting uh we have a batch of data
samples from some data collection policy
pair okay so now we have apparel
policies and um
this is this the uh there's a pair of
the don't have to roll and this drawer
will induce distribution over the state
and action pairs
also it depends on some foundation p of
the uh
this uh environment okay and goal is to
learn
a policy pair such that this gap is more
than capsule
okay so again the first study uh under
what kind of condition about this
distribution
induced by the behavioral policy
under which we can learn near
a natural equilibrium
and the first thing you may think about
is to
generalize the idea in the single agent
setting
in single agency i think we know that
you only need to cover the optimal
policy and then it's enough to recover
the neural policy okay so here can we do
the same um
so you uh the analog is corresponding
assumption is the following that's the
density region or the importance rate
between say
a pair of natural equilibrium new star
restart
or this data collection uh
policy data distribution in use by this
policy uh is upper bounded by some
constant okay so this is uh
natural generalization of the single
policy coverage in the single agent
setting
so
question uh inside the your capital d
set you meant to have a and b in there
like oh yes sorry this should be b yeah
so as a b
reward and next state
and both so both players are observing
the state the two actions chosen right
right so here we just consider because
we are in an offline setting basically
we can observe everything
and the data can be generated according
to any policy and we study what kind of
properties of this policy pair uh we can
learn a good uh nationality firm
thank you
yeah sorry so this should be bigger okay
uh okay so uh first
let's study whether this condition is
enough like we only cover one nash
equilibrium
uh our first uh
result and there's actually the key
takeaway from the talk is that this is
not possible so we give a contrary very
simple contrary example showing um this
assumption long is not uh sufficient
so
uh here's our counter example so let me
dig into a bit detail
uh so basically you have two games uh
one
uh in both games uh you have two actions
for each player say a1b1 and a1 a2 and
b1 b2 okay so
so the first game if you play a1 b1 you
get reward point five a1 b2 gotta reward
one a to b one you get one zero and a
two b two is gonna reward
point five
so for this game uh the national
equilibrium is just a one b1 okay uh we
can check that very easily because at
this point uh
there's no incentive for both player to
change action
and the second game it's um this one so
the only difference from the first game
is that we change this a2b2 to 0.5
okay
but this change also changes nash
equilibrium the national equilibrium for
game two
becomes a2 b2
okay again you can check this by there's
no incentive for both player to change
this action
okay so now let's consider the following
setting where our data set covers uh a1
b1 and a2 b2 uh with equal probability
okay so status consists of many a1 b1 a2
b2
and we observe this reward okay and this
i think we this dataset uh does cover
um the nash equilibrium uh for both
games okay
and in this setting the c single um is
two because um it's visits uh use a1 b1
a2 b2 with equal confidence
okay however the main problem uh for
this uh example is that
with only this data set you cannot
differentiate whether we are in game one
or game two
right uh because we can only observe
that uh you play a1 b1 and get point
five reward player a2 b2 got point five
word
and uh basically not differentiate this
two okay
so this is basically our contouring
example it's very simple it shows that
if you only cover you can say only cover
natural equilibrium uh it's not enough
to uh
um to learn um this nash equilibrium
okay
um so basically the inside is that you
do need some information about other
uh say action pairs in order to
identify which is
nash equilibrium
okay so what consumption can we make i
mean uh so now we need a stronger
assumption in order to learn the nash
equilibrium so this is this assumption
we make so this is a second takeaway
like we believe this is a natural
assumption
um okay so let me first introduce the
assumption
so the assumption is following so for
nash equilibrium
mu star nu star okay
we need the behavioral policy covers mu
star new for all new
and uh muse
new star for all mu
okay
so
so this table shows the intuition so
again this a1 b1 is a nash equilibrium
so we not only need to cover a1 b1 we
also need to cover all the
uh
all a1 b1 a1 b2 2 a1 say bb okay so the
entire row
also we need this entire column
say a1 b1 a2 b1 2a b1 okay
so this is um uh the unilateral coverage
assumption we propose so more formally
we assume that there is some constant
say unilateral such that the density
ratio between uh any uh d mu star nu or
zero
and the mu 2 star and 0
is upper bounded by this constant and
again our summer combat will depend on
this constant
and this requires for every
state action
um uh pair and the array policy pairs
so in this i think you can see here
there's a difference between the two
players or some game and um single agent
for a single agent setting the c single
can be and the best case can be one but
in this case c unilateral
is
in the best case it can be just a or b
because you need to cover the entire row
one column so in the uniform
distribution case it would be
a or b
and for the others
action pairs you can cover them or not
doesn't matter um but you know if you
cover some that will make your senior
lateral side bigger
okay so
uh
we also show that uh i don't think i
have time to go over this but uh you
cannot really weaken this assumption so
again we can propose some example that
uh if you only slightly violate this
assumption again you have this
identifiability issue that you can now
differentiate two games with different
nash equilibrium so basically we show
that uh this assumption cannot be
weakened
all right
so now let's go to the algorithm we show
that under its unilateral assumption you
can actually learn natural equilibrium
so for the branded case
the algorithm idea is
similar or it's natural extension of the
single agent setting so we estimate each
will work
and we obtain an upper bound and lower
bond based on say uh coefficient bonds
things like that
and then
we compute
natural equilibrium
for
using the lower bond and we contain a
pair of policies
say mu under bar new underbar and also
we compute
natural equilibrium for the upper bound
of this reward say mu upper bar new
upper bar
so this is an institution so uh we
obtained up like a interval for the
reward confidence interval for the
reward and we use upper bound to compute
one nash equilibrium is lower bound to
compute not super different
and here our output
is for the max player
as the
policy corresponds to the lower bound of
the reward
and our output for the min player is
the policy that corresponds to the upper
bond of the
reward so this represents
the idea of pessimism because um we kind
of finalized uncertain uh
uh action pairs so for both players um
we use this cosmetic uh policy to ask
our output
okay so this is our optimum idea it's a
kind of a natural extension of the
single agent setting and
for the result um
so this is unilateral coverage
assumption
we can have this kind of bond like it's
a b times c unilateral or epsilon
squared uh if you have some stronger
assumption about the coverage that's a
uniform coverage which basically means
that you cover the entire all the action
pairs and you can prove to say unif
which is the constant for
this coverage assumption
or epsilon square and for term based
games again we can obtain a stronger
bond which is c unilateral or epsilon
squared
so these results justify that this
assumption is a sufficient assumption
and furthermore as i showed before uh
this assumption is cannot be weakened so
this is kind of
a kind of complete picture about
this assumption
at least this assignment cannot be
weakened and it's also sufficient
and in terms of lower bond um
we just inherited from the single indian
setting uh with this u natural
assumption you can obtain a c unilateral
or optimum square thermal complexity so
you can see here there's a gap and it's
still open rather you can close this gap
but for the uniform coverage or
turn-based games
we can obtain the matching upper and
lower bonds
um
okay and uh
for
uh
the markov setting or the reinforcement
setting i don't think i have time to go
over all the details but basically it's
similar to the single agency i think you
do some dynamic programming as some
bonus to proper uncertainty and again
you obtain both upper and lower bounds
for
each state
action kill pose
and then you compute q functions v
function and what you output again it's
in cosmetic output for both players
and uh here
uh the most technical part is how to
design a bonus here we use a reference
function and bursting bond to obtain a
tight bonus uh to or at least to get the
dependency on the h factor the horizon
factor but our dependency on a and b are
still
not tight for
this setting
but again for uniform coverage and
uh turn-based game we have a matching
upper and lower font
so again this also shows that this
unilateral assumption is sufficient for
small curve games
okay so in summary um
so we give kind of the first circle
study on when it's possible to learn
um
this nash equilibrium offline setting
and the ti takeaway is that the single
policy coverage is not sufficient so
this is a kind of separation between the
single agent setting and the two pairs
or some setting
and the way proposed is unilateral
copied assumption which is sufficient
and cannot be weakened
and algorithm is from pessimism for both
players and
sometimes we can obtain optimal bounds
and sometimes still a polynomial uh gap
uh i also mentioned that there's a
concurrent word um
with some authors from berkeley as well
like goran
they also study uh the same setting and
also study the linear
mdp setting as well
so some open problems uh whether we can
improve this um
uh
dependency on a and b that's one uh
natural assumption of a natural question
another question is whether we can
generalize system assumption and
algorithm ideas through multi-agent
settings and we have an upcoming work
working on this directions and we'll
release it maybe a couple of weeks later
and thank you and i would like to take
some questions
thank you very much simon for a
very interesting talk
do we have any questions in the room uh
yeah
oh thanks thank you for a very nice talk
i'm wondering for the algorithm because
in the online setting when we do markup
games we usually just compute one upper
bound and one lower bound and we do the
like uh nash equilibrium with upper
bounds and lower bound together but it
seems like you are doing
nash equipment for the
for the lower bound lower bound or
um basically just you know we have you
just run uh
this algorithm twice you can obtain a
lower bond
uh for this reward and then compute
natural equilibrium
and then you compute the upper bound and
compute natural equilibrium and the
output it's uh one from the upper bound
and one from the lower yeah yeah what
i'm saying is like i think in the online
setting what do we typically do is like
we
combine our upper bounds and our lower
bounds we compute the nash equilibrium
for that general sum game
yeah i'm agreeing everyone wondering if
something like like that would work or
or that would not work um
that may work but um here is
i think this our version like at least
in offline
offline setting is you can use a simple
algorithm because you only need to
compute the
uh zero sum game you don't need to
compute the general something um so that
somehow uh
offline setting makes it simpler yeah
okay thank you
let's do this
uh thanks simon so one question
generally what is the setting where you
imagine you'll have players playing
like uh randomly and you have data
offline that of this form
um
where you also have active active
experimentation
so you're asking uh when
uh
like how this data is generated or
yeah
like what yeah like maybe you mentioned
the beginning uh for like like the
practical scenarios where you have
offline data people not playing enough
equilibrium or some other equilibrium
notion
yeah
and not having the ability of active
experimentation
um
oh i mean what practical applications
you may have this kind of
in the game applications you can
actively experiment so it's not offline
right so
ah okay
uh yeah that's right in some investment
setting um i mean of course it's based
on some assumptions you do not want to
really interact uh with the environment
and in some recommendation system
uh some time you can also model as a
game and where you are uh you know you
know interacting it's online it's a kind
of costly so you want to use some
offline data
yeah everybody in games you do have uh
ability to
uh you know you have a simulator so you
can get a lot of data
for example would you expect if people
do some no regret learning or something
some other form of learning that's
natural that your
coverage criterion will be satisfied
uh so you mean when this uh condition
will be satisfied yeah so if you have
some form of learning players when you
collect data from learning agents that
use some form of
learning algorithm would your coverage
be
satisfied uh that's a good question so
for
i'm not sure about no
uh regret learning whether you can
generate data set that satisfies our
assumption
but one simple example is that if you
uh you know both players play the
actions uniformly randomly then you can
have a data set like scissor or
something
well
all right so um
i have one question so um if like um
what is what would be a generalization
of this coverage to
you know like infinite action
spaces and stuff like that like
okay
either in single rl or or like or
you know
even just normal form like single shot
game
uh for example in the
linear setting what you need is a
kind of
a least angle value of the quarance
matrix collected by
defined on your feature space that's
what people use for linear setting
for more general if you have a feature
space
for more general settings
i'm not sure i think they're
sometimes people still use this kind of
density ratio to
or this yeah density ratio to define the
uh coverage
all right thank you so uh let's you know
in the interest of time let's take
further questions offline thank you
simon
for your excellent
talk and next up we have sylvana
you want to set up